hello everyone and welcome to round five
of this year's fiday World rapid
Championship it is Ian chaparo versus
rard rort and this is the sort of most
requested game of round five it's a very
short one so I'm going to show this one
first this video will contain two games
the other one uh being The Clash of
leaders Magnus Carlson versus Timor GV
as GV went into this round uh at four
out of four so we're going to check out
that one as well but first this one uh
it's really really a gem so chaparo
versus rard Rapport even with the white
pieces opens with Pawn to E4 we have
Pawn to C6 Rapport goes for the Caro KH
defense uh Knight to F3 and now Pawn to
D5 striking in the center saw fairly
standard motive D3 and now of course you
could capture but here Queen to C7 raer
now looking to trade Queens early on we
have Knight to C3 and D captures on e4
we have D captures and now Knight to D7
and already as of move five we have a
completely new game so okay Pawn to A4
you know that if black decides to Castle
Queens set at some point it might be
useful like if Knight B6 you can chase
it away with A5 and um I go after an
attack against the black king So Knight
G2 F6 and Bishop to C4 now the Knight
does come to B6 as it comes with Tempo
Bishop to B3 and now Bishop to G Bishop
to G4 we have Pawn to H3 and just Bishop
captures an F3 you could throw in the in
between Rook to d8 does look nice but
after Bishop to D2 you will still have
to side um probably to capture here and
after Queen captures it's not really a
problem black white will just Castle
Queen side here so instead Bishop
captures and F3 was played Queen
captures and pawn to E6 now we have
Bishop to G5 uh and now Knight B to D7
again castling here makes a lot of sense
but rapper doesn't like it he goes
Knight to D7 first probably fighting for
that E5 Square he doesn't want to see e
uh E5 here but the thing is even if you
Castle here uh uh Pawn to E5 is not um
an option so it's hard to say why this
was um discarded but okay he went Knight
B to D7 uh kingside Castle not queenside
castles kingside Castle this is also
very odd but as queenside castles was
expected probably he wanted to have
castles on opposite sides of the board
Bishop to D6 and now Rook a to D1 uh we
have Pawn to H6 and now Bishop back to
E3 and pawn to G5 by Rober preparing to
attack with Pawn to G4 so Rook F to E1
and now not Pawn to G4 the move you'd
expect but first Rook to G8 or you could
play G4 H captures and only then play
Rook to G8 uh Bishop to D4 uh and now
Rook to G6 and Rook to G6 is not the
absolute best by opport uh G4 right away
is the way to go but here after Rook to
G6 he blunders um a very a very cool
move uh but the problem is chiarino
doesn't see it and I'm sure you guys see
it so I'm just going to show it here E5
is very very strong for white point is
that after Knight captures an E5
attacking the queen you will just attack
the Knight Queen E3 and what do you do
now you can't really uh move the Knight
if you play something like Knight E7
then just Bishop captures on E6 and you
get uh completely shattered Here pawn
captures Queen captures King to f8 now
Knight to E4 comes attacks the bishop
here attacks the the Knight three times
and uh well after something like Bishop
to E5 you will play Queen to F5 you
attack The Rook here and once the king
defends The Rook something like Knight
to C5 and now you're threatening an E5
you're threatening Knight to E6 Fork to
win the black queen so there really
isn't all that much you can do here if
Rook to E8 you have to stop the the main
threat then Knight captures and D7 and
after Queen captures you will just play
Rook captures on E5 and you've
completely uh shattered Black's defenses
Rook captures on E5 Queen captures and
that's pretty much it well
materialistically white is only up one
Pawn but look at that black king that's
not going to going to be um you know
very nice so instead what you could do
instead of moving the KN back you could
hope maybe to hold by defending an E5 uh
but then the Knight comes to E4 and is
just a much much better position for
white not clear how black would actually
continue this game uh but okay both of
them uh missed the idea so Queen to E2
was played now you are ready to strike
with E5 but now of course Bishop to E5
uh we have Knight to D5 even did not
spot that sacrifice but spots this one
and it doesn't really work but it works
well enough so C captures and D5 was
played e captures and D5 and now Bishop
captures on D4 and of course you don't
touch the bishop D captures on E6 so
this is how he's breaking through H and
now the the best way to defend would be
just Knight to C5 point being that if
Rook captures on D5 and F captures on E6
uh the Knight defends here so you cannot
capture with a heavy piece you're going
to have to play with something like
Bishop captures but then you move the
king and everything is fine uh but here
Bishop captures on F2 check was played
and this just doesn't work Queen
captures on F2 uh Knight to C5 now and E
captures an F7 with check King to f8 and
queen to F5 attacking The Rook here King
to G7 defending and now what did Rapport
miss here there's only one move that
wins but I'm pretty sure you guys see it
um even without pausing the video of
course the move is Rook to E8 and uh now
you're probably wondering but why Rook
Rook to E8 it's defended by the pawn uh
sorry it's defended by the by the Knight
how how are we to gain anything from
this uh well that's exactly it you will
remove uh you will remove the Knight so
Rook captures on8 was played and now of
course you realize um chiarino idea
Queen captures on F6 in the style of the
great Rashid ninov and he was in this
position un move 25 that rard Rapport
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here it doesn't matter
what you capture with uh Rook or the
king King uh next comes F captures on E8
and you bring a knight into the game
with a monster triple Fork here uh or a
a royal Fork if you will and that's just
it once you move uh the queen will be
captured and white will be up a full
Bishop so of course being up up a piece
at this level that this is resigns
territory so brilliant stuff by chaparo
there was uh you know some wiggle room
in the in the middle of the game that uh
they both had a chance to improve but
you know chaparo spotted that beautiful
sacrifice on D5 and then raport missed
the whole Rook to E8 idea the geometry
was there but yeah you know with uh I
mean they did have time on the clock
they both had above five minutes on the
clock so it's um not something you
should miss this King to G7 move yeah
but it pretty much any other move here
is also resigns that there's no good
move to play here uh you cannot defend
the the Knight and the Rook here so very
nicely done by Chap parinov and now
let's check out the other game of the
leaders that is Magnus car versus teor
GV also a fairly short one let's check
it out so Magnus had the white pieces
here and he opened with E4 we have Pawn
to E5 Knight to F3 we have Knight to C6
and now Bishop to B5 D Lopez and tamur
goes for uh the morphe defense uh the
the brilliant defense doesn't really fit
his style uh Bishop to A4 and now Pawn
to D6 we have castles and Bishop to D7
and Timor garv also known as the
blindfold King went into this round like
I mentioned with four out of four so the
only one standing uh in front you know
um uh in front of him opposing that five
out of five is Magnus Carlson with Pawn
to C3 uh and usually G6 and Knight G to
E7 are played here but that is not g
style he goes for Pawn to G5 right away
and okay Magnus can only wait and see
what he does D4 there comes G4 Knight to
E1 and pawn to H5 as well very very nice
uh Bishop to E3 and now there are a
couple games where Bishop to G7 was
played but here we have Bishop to H6 and
it is now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so okay Queen to E2
by Magnus and now Queen to F6 of course
trading doesn't really do
anything uh merely improves White's
position so Queen to F6 uh D captures on
E5 D captures and now Knight to D3 we
have Knight GT E7 uh and Knight to D2
and now comes Knight to G6 uh preparing
to put more pressure on magnus's King
side uh Knight to C5 putting pressure on
the B7 pawn and now uh probably everyone
thought Ur would just Castle here you
Castle you defend the the pawn here The
Rook will come to defend the bishop here
H but no he wents he he goes back Bishop
to C8 and this is just very very strange
it's like he doesn't want to give uh
Magnus a clear Target um to go after his
King so okay Rook 8 to D1 the king
remains in the center of the board uh
Knight to F4 now G goes for the attack
we have Bishop captures on F4 and now
Bishop captures you'd think e captures
was the way to go but really no because
there's E5 and black is just in a
terrible position for example Queen to
G6 Knight to D to E4 now comes with
Knight to F6 check next and white is
just much better so instead after Bishop
captures on F4 we have Bishop captures
and now Knight to D3 going back after
the bishop uh castles King side now by
teamour and now Pawn to G3 attacks the
bishop Bishop H6 and now Pawn to F4 and
the way to capture his is e captures an
F4 it looks a bit odd because you know
this looks looks better but it's not
after Knight captures you will play B5
kick away the bishop to B3 or to C2 and
then you will get your knight to E5 stop
E5 that way and you have a very very
nice position with black however G
captures on F3 alaan was played and now
Knight captures on F3 and Bishop to G4
so uh GV is fighting but as you can see
he's already down to 5 minutes on the
clock whereas Magnus has over 12 minutes
on the clock uh Queen to G2 Magnus just
unpins here and queen to E6 we have
Bishop to B3 now attacking the queen but
more than that putting the bishop on
this powerful diagonal H we have Queen
to E7 and now Pawn to H3 getting rid of
the bishop Bishop to E6 and now Knight
to H4 the bishop is the Knight is now
coming to F5 uh Bishop to E3 with check
King to H2 and now Queen to G5 trying to
get some sort sort of activity here on
the king side Knight to F5 and now
Bishop back to B6 as the Knight on F5
also attacks the bishop and you really
don't want to give up your light Square
Bishop to eliminate this Knight so
Bishop back to B6 Now Pawn to H4 Queen
to F6 and now Queen to E2 putting
pressure on the H5 Pawn so Queen to h8
defending and now Pawn to G4 Magnus
breaks through on the king side here and
he wants to use the G file for his Rooks
we have Queen to H7 uh and now PA on to
G5 even uh captures here does seem like
like a possibility but after King to h8
uh you will also give black the use of
the G file for his Rook so instead
Magnus advances the pawn to
G5 and now King to h8 we have Knight to
H6 uh you won that square by advancing
the pawn to G5 and now Bishop captures
on B3 a captures and pawn to F6 and it
looks like black is holding here you
cannot capture as the Knight will hang
uh but Queen captures on H 5 gets the
queen into the game and now G6 is coming
so how do you prevent G6 well Bishop to
E3 now you cannot play this because just
Queen captures on H6 but now Rook D to
E1 Magnus harass harasses the bishop and
if you try to attack The Rook then The
Rook just follows the bishop so there's
really uh no trying that and if you go
back G6 just wins the game on the spot
so F captures on G5 was played he tried
giving up material here Rook captures an
f8 with check Rook captures and here
Rook captures an E3 and it was in this
position on move 36 that teor gareev
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here there's uh not uh
not much to try you're down a full piece
and you don't have any compensation you
don't have any checks this is covered by
the night and if you try to gain some
activity even H captures on G5 this is
just unplayable it's uh it would be it
would be uh you know a Monumental task
even finding a a a move to play here
with black there there's just nothing
here uh so yeah very nicely done by
Magnus and they um Magnus and in the
previous game chaparo are the two
leaders after the five rounds of Rapid I
will now as all of the games probably
have finished now yeah we have four
people on four and a half so it's Magnus
Carlson yongi Ian chaparo and viit also
lands on four and a half out of five he
defeats Maxim chav in the final round uh
then if you guys are interested on four
and a half we have Maxim Vash gra danil
dubov uh an Anton David Garo Alexander
shimanov Timur GV also on four out of
five as he went against Magnus with four
out of four kirol shenko Shang shishu we
have Ral mamadov Conrad Holt also the
the the man of the hour who defeated
chakar mamaro in that spectacular game
if you haven't seen it it's my previous
video do check it out uh also Drew danil
dubov in round four and defeated Jordan
fforest in round five so probably games
to check out uh and Sandy panand also on
four out of five so 14 people
people uh well four people on four and a
half out of five and 10 people on four
out of five it's a really really uh
wonderful tournament uh we'll see what
happens tomorrow as we continue I I
think we still have uh five more rounds
tomorrow and then on the last day uh it
will not be five on the last day it will
be three rounds uh but yeah uh really
really much enjoyed this hope you guys
have enjoyed it as well and yeah use
that use that hashtag suggestion a lot
of games are being played I cannot uh
even begin to to check out all of of
them so I mostly check out the players
that I I enjoy watching myself if
there's a fun game I will show it I rely
on your hashtag suggestion also to
uncover you know hidden gems and yeah
mostly I will show a Magnus game because
he's the the defending World rapid and
Blitz champion and you know when the
game start I usually start following his
game and then I check out all the other
games as well and if it's an interesting
one I will show it but yeah mostly I'm
relying on your hashtag suggestion for
other games uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys or rather those were the
games hope you enjoyed it I would like
to thank ja sha s OA Isaac Davis Martin
gor Papik and Timothy rosan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions but mostly
following the Fay World rapid
Championship uh thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your
day